I may totally have my my death
site what is up everybody we are now
live for our I don't even know how much
how many of these code Gia streams we've
done but we are live and we're looking
forward to it yeah actually when we
first started this cods live stream it
was supposed to be a one-off thing uh we
just did it one Saturday like the
Christmas uh Eve day uh back in December
because uh there was a lot of demand
people were saying they wanted to talk
about Kias the live so like okay let's
do the live stream and since then people
have been requesting it so much that
we've kept doing it every Saturday at
noon Eastern Standard Time and we've
gotten a lot of support a lot of people
participating so thank you guys and
welcome everyone who is here welcome
everyone in the chat I'm looking forward
to this in this one we're going to be
talking about all the craziest theories
for code Gia season 3 including joke
theories including you know outlandish
theories all that kind of stuff so yeah
thank you for joining us and also if you
have general questions be sure to uh put
those in there as well we'll try to
answer them to the best of our ability
and let me just introduce who is with me
today we have Goen my brother and fellow
anime aoran what's up Goen what up
people glad to be here as always what up
people what up people I I actually
referenced that in the chat I hope
people got the death not reference nice
we also have soul Maka one of our
Discord Vice Roy what's up bro yeah man
I'm good I'm good glad to be here as
always yeah welcome bro and of course we
have the Lord Chancellor himself Vector
Maximus I am
Gundam oh that's
sick no but the real Vector is actually
a human boy yeah and yeah I'm totally
totally a Gundam as you can plainly see
now that I'm no longer in Shadow he is a
human but yeah last time Vector was on
he was complete Shadow but now he's
actually gotten into the light and his
his hair has vanished the night as you
can see
guys gaze upon its Glory I know it's
it's amazing hair just
say golden coer so the first the first
thing I want to talk about is actually
there's a there was a funny by the way
guys if you don't know we have a Discord
server uh the link is in the description
where we when we're not making videos
we're not making streams we're still
discussing um code gas theories and
waifu wars and all that stuff so if you
you can go there H link is in the
description and basically we recently
had we had a discussion where some
people proposed on the Discord that the
theory the crazy theory that nanali has
been the bad guy in code guas the main
bad guy all along that nanali is behind
it all that the whole thing was
applauded by her to become the empress
and that she will be the main villain of
season 3 so that's the first uh crazy
theory that I would like to discuss
because that kind of inspired this whole
discussion so yeah what do you guys
think about that Vector I think you were
there for
much yeah I was there for basically the
whole conversation and I
mean it's definitely a funny Theory um
so basically the whole thing is like you
know you know she she acts all innocent
the whole series but then when she
actually does open her eyes you know she
doesn't she doesn't require any time
readjusting to the light at all so she
had her eyes open the whole time when
Lou wasn't looking so she was obviously
plotting something and then the fact of
the matter is that despite you know like
firing the FL and probably racking up a
higher kill count than even like uh than
Colin by the end of the series because
of that um she and then she just gets to
be the Empress of Britannia and you know
all that stuff obviously she ploted it
all from the start she's a master
manipulator yes yeah that is interesting
because yeah she opens her eyes kind of
like she breaks Charles's guos like all
of a sudden and then yeah she insists
that she wants to be the one to push the
button for the F out remember that guys
that was weird I I thought that was kind
of weird actually and yeah in the end
she gets to be the empress with her
hands clean even though she launched the
flare and killed all of those people
like that that is when you think about
it it is a little bit Shady e yeah so
what do you what do you say yeah yeah
definitely definitely I think um it was
probably uh hinted at with uh Nightmare
on N I think I think that's was the
offer's way of uh kind of getting us
mentally prepared for the uh for the new
villain coming
in that's what I think so you're saying
that nanali is the nightmare oh
yes Illuminati confirmed Illuminati
confirmed by it is confirmed you guys
and I just want to welcome all the
people in the chat we got Ambu Itachi
shik tono Dark Sonic what's up bro creep
Ellen rev freshh who's asking what is
code gas and for this reason he will be
banned right now I'm just
kidding instantly Struck from the record
never to be mentioned again in polite
company Oh Holy Knight has a good theory
he says that Arthur actually the cat
actually received guos and is now going
to be one of the villains of season
three that's a that's an interesting one
is Arthur gonna side with uh nanali or
with someone else that's it's a whole
another can of worms well we also got
zero of course we got Phantom H what's
up Phantom H what's up bro how's
Germany
well
obviously oops
sorry say if if we looking at arur and
looking at the uh the mythology with
like the names used like gav and all the
rest of them then um arur is gonna have
to have a son and that's going to be his
murderer and he'll probably take over
and that'll be our Tyrant totally and he
and his guos is going to let him
transform all the humans into uh into
Nikos oh man that would be so popular if
that Happ mice mice so they're easier to
conquer the Arthur spin-off of codos is
the next big thing man with nekos being
so popular wow that's a good idea we
gotta we gotta get on this we got gotta
get on this guys like well someone touch
with client plays ATT on Titan did that
one like high school spin-off I think
this wouldn't be absurd I think this
could happen we also I want to say what
up to Gabriel lucido movet what's up man
what's up he busy with school so he
hasn't been chatting that much in the
Discord but we miss you bro we got cly
Cordo we got Jos elwin Azura 24
Raider bo bo is here what's up bro
Renee yeah lots of people lots of peeps
welcome everyone glad to have you here
and yeah as you see from the title we
are discussing the craziest theories in
code gas for code gas season 3 and we
just we just were discussing evil non
and we're going to go back to this
Theory I think it's a big one what if
Nal was evil the whole time and also the
Arthur theory that the reason Arthur's
the cat his name is Arthur is because he
is truly the king behind the scenes
right so you know it was no coincidence
that he took the mask of zero it was no
coincidence you
guys Goen yo you haven't spoken yet tell
us what you think about the N Theory
first of all I just want to say I want I
want the title of this video to be
Vector Maximus face reveal
everyone's asking got the most views
some people some people in the chat were
like ho Vector Maximus is real they just
yeah I do in fact exist I'm not just
like an AI That's running the server
obvious they assumed you were just a a
server bot who gained
sentient oh yes I achieved
apotheosis guys this is like this is
like an death no where L just sends his
Butler to kind of do his work like this
OB obviously isn't Vector Maximus this
is just a filling obviously totally
screen with just a black
v celay v but with the non stuff let's
get back to serious serious theories
serious um with the non stuff I think it
was that you you're right to bring up
the F because I don't think yui ever
would have done it I mean there was
there was a lot of par between an and
yui especially because they both they
both wanted to have more power to like
make the world a better
place and they were sick of people
telling them what to do and take and not
having any agency but it is I mean I I
can't see yui ever firing the FIA so
whereas yui got her power by appealing
to the masses and Collective Goodwill
none only got her power by using nukes
yeah so there is a big difference there
and I don't know like I mean it is
farfetched just because not only is is
Lou's Ron Detra but otherwise I I could
see
it like I mean if you look at the
character objectively it's like she can
be brainwashed into thinking that she's
doing good even though she's behaving
poorly yeah and I I I just want to say
what up to zero sun is here too Camille
is here Boon solim Joseph zarur I
recognize Joseph he's always here what's
up bro thanks for coming we got who else
do we have we have shardul sones hey man
I see him in the comments for to videos
all the time welcome guys jro the hero
oh where is he jro the hero he said he's
talking about having a Photoshop pick of
zero without a mask and then just
putting vector's face on
there I need to go look through the
comments to see that yeah oh yeah I see
it and if you guys don't know who Vector
is that means that you need to join our
Discord server Link in the description
because that's where we chat on a daily
basis all the time and Vector is the the
hand of the king in the server so you
gotta go respect join us there you
guys and yeah so evil nalite is a thing
um is a thing guys and one other thing I
wanted to say is there's going to be a
new code gas U video coming out this
weekend and actually it's going to be a
a different one is going to be an
interactive one so definitely be sure to
check that out and look out for that and
what this video is going to be
is okay so everyone loves wfu Wars right
everyone loves Wu Wars Wu Wars only in
the Wu Wars chat yes and we have we have
a special wifeu Wars chat on the Discord
server if you guys want to just go all
out with the w Wars but we know that Co
is full full of um potential vus right
so I I wanted to take because me and
Goen both fight all the time my brother
Goen about who um whose wifeu Colin
would be because we both say Colin is
our wifeu and then we fight over it so
then I wanted to find a good code gas
waiu quiz like you know like one of
those online quizzes where it's like who
is your codas Wu and so that we could
both take it and then we see who really
is you know um who would get Colin and
who wouldn't but I could not find any
good code gas Wu quizzes so what I
decided to do is to create my own code
gas wifeu quiz and I will make Goen take
it live like in a video and I will be
looking over him and he'll be taking it
and as he takes it you'll be able to
take it too we'll have the we'll have
the quiz uh the link to the quiz so
you'll be able to take the quiz with us
and then we'll all see who gets what
wifeu and there's going to be 11
questions seven different options seven
different Wu options you can imagine how
much time I have to spend coming up with
seven questions that apply 11 questions
that apply to seven different people so
yeah this is is going to be a good quiz
guys and you we're all going to be able
to take it together so yeah look out for
that soon either today or tomorrow we'll
see yeah excited Vector I want to hear
from Vector are you excited about this
about the quiz yes yeah I'm looking
forward to it I'm because like um I'm
not sure you were there when all of us
when a whole bunch of people on the
server did uh this quiz to basically
determine uh you know which code guos
character you were and I was suzaku it
turns out um but uh I'm interested to
see if you can do a better job than that
quiz because it was basically you have
four choices and they were so blatantly
obvious which character they were meant
for yeah so I mean I'm really interested
to see how you pull this off because I'm
not quite sure how you do
it yeah hopefully there's a situation
where it's more personality based so it
won't be like too obvious yeah you will
see I think I did a good job but then
again I always think I do a good job but
yeah like there is quizzes out there
like cod ask like which character are
you but there is no true wifeu quiz so
this wfu quiz hopefully will be the quiz
to to end all quizzes when it comes to
codeos wuss guys but yeah let's uh so
yeah look out for that look out for uh
definitely uh you're G to be the first
to know if you're on Discord you're
gonna be the first to know when that is
coming out and then we're going to
continue that
debate um yesterday we actually had a
quiz on Discord about wuss cods wuss and
c21 over Colin by like two votes guys
there was like supporters where
C2 won by like I think like 50 people
voted altogether and it was like good
turnout yeah and C2 won by like two
votes guys so yeah I I voted colins so I
was a little bit disappointed but you
know maybe we can do a rematch one of
these days and then we'll see how it
goes I feel like people just thought you
know Colin's obviously GNA win there's
no even point for me to vote but this is
why this is why you need to vote right
in the your vote counts in the important
wifeu election yeah like like unlike
politics this is like real [__] man yeah
this is like you can't just set this one
out man this is Wu Wars man this this
counts this matters I mean friendships
have been broken over these Wu Wars you
must take them seriously Wars R serious
yeah wifeu Wars risk and uh Mario
Party yes true true Mario Party and risk
are both things that me and Goen play
regularly and enjoy and he will tell you
that I win most of the time
he even will admit it won't you Goen not
Mario party but yes Mario Party yes
Mario Party he gets lucky but I win more
mini games which means I'm more like I'm
better at the game but yeah but it's not
about the mini games bro like Napoleon
wasn't just about artillery
bro Napoleon totally was about artillery
but whatever yeah but take other things
into
account Victory is on the side of he who
has the most
artillery any other any other um crazy
theories that we can get into anyone in
the chat has some other crazy theories
that we can uh
explore well well what I'm thinking like
with um
n I'm thinking it is possible that she
could become an antagonist in in a
fashion maybe partly due to uh losing
Louch rather than it being like you know
her being a mastermind from get but uh
in a realistic sense maybe it could be
like that after losing Louch that kind
of like pushes her to see things like
kind of differently and then like forces
her then to act possibly and like Louch
how Louch kind of disregarded what Nali
wanted for him to do what he believed
was best for her I think she could do
the same and disregard what like others
want or even Louch wants for what she
believes would be better
I
guess well I mean it goes with the role
of empress so wouldn't be too
surprised okay so the crazy Theory
that's being floated in the chat right
now is that C2 is really a man and no
guys that's no gender let's go if
anything would ruin this show it's that
if a man then everybody's genderbended
and we're just not going down that road
down like there's crazy theories and
there's crazy theories like we we can't
we can't go with the C2 uh being like
that would traumatize us all there there
is crazy and then there is Blasphemous
and that is Blasphemous exactly I agree
I agree no
blasphemy there is no blasphemy burn the
heretic oh and by the way uh Phantom H
uh pointed out the
Australians uh Theory which is my
favorite meme on our Discord server
which I mean definite um yeah if someone
wants to link it in the chat like
Phantom if you want to link the image in
the chat I give you permission um
because yeah he created an image that uh
makes fun of the whole Australia alien
stuff that I talk about in some of the
videos so yeah that that's my favorite
uh meme from the Discord and we have a
whole uh chat room in the Discord for
meme Wars so yeah there's a lot of Ming
going on there's a lot of wful Wars
going on there's a lot of theory chats
going on so yeah if you want to join the
Discord link is in the description and
yeah fun times I'll throw it in the chat
as well by the way B says gingers are
Blasphemous so ging are not Blasphemous
We Are Beautiful Creatures and a
blessing from God to all you Mortals
shots fire creatures I love
it yeah um yeah there's another theory
in it about
um uh Lou and C2 becoming one being and
becoming like the uh representation that
was in in
Akito oh yeah I saw that too um a couple
people poting out if you've seen Akito
the exiled and you see that um being
with code that appears a few times and
also in the end with Leila uh a couple
people pointed out that she looks like
her physical appearance seems like a
mixture between situ and Lou in terms of
like hair color and all these other
things so some people were saying what
if she's some kind of like future
mingling or or coming together of of C2
and Lou to create like a collective sort
of superior being which I I I think I
don't think so I think she is a a
representation of the collective
consciousness of the Ragnar is ancient
civilization but I'm open to discussion
if someone wants to make an argument for
it how would that work well obviously
she he's uh she is either uh Louch and
sit's kid from the future who's come
back for some reason or it's just
then that would explain the similarities
and appearance or it's just the fact
that clamp has a very distinctive and
consistent
style then that's why they look
similar it's one of the two and I think
some of it is also like just the style
of drawing because yeah yeah in code gas
I mean you can only create variation to
an extent but that is an interesting
idea but that would be funny if it was
the kid from the future like this next
time first we ripped off Gundam Seed now
we're ripping off uh now we're ripping
off Terminator we're gonna have some fun
with
it let's just see how many how many
shows we how many fandoms we can get
pissed at us for taking stuff from
them but like they did it good they did
it good but there's so much similarities
between kogas and gam seed it's
insane um T Taylor Smith says C2 is
secretly a man still best
waifu I actually and uh saada says that
he doesn't want any time travel in COD
gas like yeah I think that would be like
there is some hints right because some
of the like uh bismar walstein seems to
have a guos that can let him see through
time so and like actually see in the
future so there is some hits that
perhaps guos power could mess with time
so we don't know for sure and Rolo too
to an extent like he does perception of
time yeah perception though perception
yeah still time related I thought that
the explanation for bismarks had been
that it's like it's reading their
movements in advance that's why like um
in the case of suzaku he's moving just
too fast too fast for even his guos to
compensate and be able to accurately
predict what he's going to do like I
thought that was the explanation not
that he's actually like seeing the
future yeah I thought it was like
prediction kind of like the Shing gun in
Naruto and that kind of thing but
prediction isn't prediction seeing the
future
no it's just predict no yeah there's a
there's a fine line there of Distinction
it's that you know seeing what way
something's traveling and then you know
working out okay it's gonna end up there
yeah the trajectory yeah following that
so I I interpreted that he can see like
5 seconds into the future or something
like that was my interpretation when I
watched it um also Naruto 9765 tanu asks
didn't the creator of codos declare that
Louch was dead and I actually I I want
to address this because there were some
rumors saying that the creator of Kia
said that Louch lamp Peru's story was
over finished and this is when initially
the series ended now of course I always
thought he was alive and what I thought
that the Creator was saying was Lou
larou the the being we know as L larou
the person was dead in the sense that he
was killed by suzaku but then he became
he came back to life as an immortal
being with code so just like C2 no
longer has her original name when she
has code she becomes C2 so too would
Louch become have another name now
whether R2 or something else he would
now no longer be the Louch we know but
he would still be Lou just brought back
to life and so I thought that that uh
comment by the Creator was actually kind
of like a troll kind of like a
misleading thing to tell you and I think
that confirming the sequel actually
confirms that fact that the Creator was
trolling us the whole time when he said
that because clearly we know now that he
didn't die we don't know exactly how he
survived but we're guessing that it's
because of code so yeah I think that was
a troll comment on on behalf of the the
Creator um I I wouldn't call it a troll
I wouldn't call it a troll I'd say
probably it probably was um the the
production company at that time couldn't
like continue the story so at that time
it was like okay yeah we're done with it
then that's it yeah he we end the story
here in it but then after now they've
decided no look we need something to
bring the money in finish off your story
you know what I mean so he's like all
right okay then and then you know it's
coming back now and I like the idea of
him saying like Lou is dead cuz Louch is
gone and he's supposed to like be done
and his identity is gone and I always
interpret it like that so I like that
interpretation because it's true Louch
lamp rou is done there's going to be no
more of him yeah he could be L2 now yeah
he can't be L lamperouge anymore because
I mean that kind of died at the end of
suzaku's Sword it's much the way that
suzaku can't be uh suzaku anymore he can
only be zero yeah but he's out of the
that's the thing in the PV he's out of
his uniform so what's going on oh wait
actually he might he might actually be
V2 because um in what one is it I think
it's uh Reena there was a female
V2 her name was
shiori so it's believed that she was one
of the original V2s and obviously we
know um Vincent became a V2 so maybe
that code then has that title of V2 and
when Louch got that code now maybe he's
going to be the new V2 yeah that's
another theory about uh the code that
it's it's not really your initials like
R2 that it's the code has its own name
so C2 is code the code name uh V2 is the
code name and then that name passes on
to whoever possesses the code so the
idea then would be that the none who
gave C2 her code was before that known
as C2 herself so that is I think an
interesting Theory actually and that was
also well if if we're going by that then
also from uh Rena there's
a which supports the theory that there's
more than two code Bears because if each
one just inherits the name then that
means that there's at least three codes
yeah yeah and there was also the the
theory that uh some someone brought up I
think Soul you and Vector talked about
this before that because there is eight
thought elevators that there could be
eight code bearers at the same time one
for each thought elevator right yeah no
that was his initial yeah that's my my
personal take on it is that it thought
elevator like um a clumping almost like
a hub for the collective unconsciousness
and a way for it to interact with the
world so it interact with the world
through the through the code bearers and
the guos users so there's one for each
thought elevator almost like Warden yeah
so with uh You2 and also that skull that
was able to give GE it it gives the idea
that yeah there could be more than just
two um code
users yeah and that I like that theory
um Vector I like that theory so good
work and I also want to say that mono
sit is here too in the chat and he's
also from Greece so with creepen now we
have at least two people from Greece in
the chat yes OS baby
elos and someone else said
something we got Kia and the eight
thought elevators no no no no that's
hilarious good one this is a new Theory
from like today I think in the Discord I
think I saw this in the chat today where
someone said there's going to be a CR
over between kodas and konia and the
eight seals and is going to be called
konia and the eight thought
elevators it's cold cold Nexia cold
Nexia and Louch and the eight4 elevators
but please no please no no more no more
she's a goddess no more please at least
the animation before Lou becomes God
before becomes God oh yeah oh yeah oh
look we have a guy called nois sanakis
or sanakis so that guy you know that
guy's Greek what's up buddy shout out to
elas sorry go ahead did I interrupt
someone no no okay cool you're just
saying it's just that time when there's
awkward silence yeah in life there is
often awkward silence embrace the
awkwardness embrace the silence marinate
the awkwardness oh by the way I am
completely immune to awkwardness now
because I I just made that ASMR anime
ASMR
video after that nothing nothing makes
me feel awkward after that guys I don't
know if guys I edited it and now I feel
like you know I need to see a
therapy you do that you do that check
check it out though if you haven't seen
it it's pretty
funny V Victor meski says he is Polish
shout out to Poland movet is also polish
and me and Goen are both Slavic as well
we're Serbian so yeah what's up my
brothers how you
doing I love I love the global Community
I love it so much hash animac
ASMR that's what we're gonna be known
for from now
on yeah I said if that video gets 3,000
likes and it never will I will make an
ASMR
video I completely missed that part I'm
gonna have to go like the video
now I put it in the comments
I I deliberately pulled a completely
unrealistic insane number of uh likes
like none of our videos have ever gotten
3,000 likes so just you wait when you
have like 100,000 Subs then we'll then
then in the we'll link them all back to
that and like say anim you said You' do
it you have to do it now oh oh yeah well
I'm gonna
like oh yeah but yeah ASMR fun times you
should guys should see my recommendation
feed now oh man after watching those
videos oh oh one girl that loves animac
and she's just going to create 3,000
accounts and just
do please no
please please do it people please I want
to see him
suffer yeah crazy theories
guys yeah the crazy theory that
someone's going to make 3,000 accounts
simply so anac has to suffer through
more
ASMR definitely I do like your idea
animac though about the the crossover
between fat day night and like code guos
where no death not that was death not it
could it could be similar for code guos
that could be a crazy Theory it's never
gonna happen but my want because someone
just said who was it Renee Rene says
plot twist ryuk gets bored again and
drops the death note and N only gets it
so yeah
too much too many Powers too many Powers
Yeah too much power in the hands of n
too much power yeah everyone thinks she
so innocent but no my my one idea I like
that idea but my one idea was that there
should be more Death Note but they
should have like a like the the
Shinigami decide to have a competition
and one Shinigami drops a Death Note on
each continent so let's say there's like
six Death Note users and they have like
a basically a competition who's going to
who can eliminate the other death node
users and become the Master of the world
or whatever so kind of like a Fates the
Fate series meets Death Note kind of
thing I think that would be cool brought
that up yeah I could see it I could see
it yes by the way creep Ellen says Cod
geese so yeah that's the that's the
thing because I obviously I say code
guos because that is guos is how it's
said in the dubbed and in um the sub
it's called the G
so if I was saying you would all call me
a weeb and you know it like Goen would
be standing behind me while I'm
recording the video just screaming at me
weeb that's why I just use the dub
version but that's something like bro
it's not called gios it's called Geiss
man it's called Geiss
man so then by the way our friend melot
used that in his uh code gas joke
theories video because actually that was
one of the things that inspired me for
this stream uh I put the link in the
description if you want to see it it's
called mut's Uh code gas joke video and
it's basically him having like uh
talking about some joke outlandish
theories for might what might happen in
season 3 essentially what we're doing
right now so if you want to check that
out it's very funny I definitely
recommend it and yeah he definitely
referenced Cod
geese L is gonna kick God out of heaven
and take it over
confirmed to quote his video yes and and
the other the other funny thing is that
um what about the origins of of cod and
gas we don't know but could it be
related to geese perhaps Canada geese
yeah Canadian geese exactly bring Canada
in
please it was the result of them eat uh
having too much maple
syrup yeah because like these geese live
in really cold conditions man like
that's not normal like we have here in
Niagra Niagara area in Canada geese that
they're here all like they don't even go
south they're like screw that bro I'm
staying here in the winter like that's
that's some mutated stuff man now
they're just lazy that's all it is the
south is too
far yeah like some leave but some are
like no I just see them outside like
house you have like a little artificial
Lake outside our house and they're just
chilling there like skating on the ice
like they don't
care anime Recon invading the
stream he's raiding man the walls man
the wall
Recon what up bro tell me when you
finish gold Gia so we can have you on
this stream buddy been telling you to
finish it I know you're busy though
animon makes like three videos a day
he's like we should all be we should all
strive to be like
him no sleep no sleep is for the
week or for the
S yeah so shardul sonis actually
mentions that Sunrise didn't expect a
coach to be a hit and I've heard this
rumor before that they wanted initially
to have 75 episodes but then they ended
up stopping at 50 which could again
explain that uh why they sto in that
time where people think Louch is dead
and then they were like okay well we
don't have the budget anymore whatever
so we'll say yeah that story is over but
then uh now that they saw that the
series has been had a lasting popularity
has an international following they were
like okay well now we can actually
continue the story the way we want
wanted to which would also explain that
poster from 2009 that hinted that was a
clear hint that there should be a season
3 or a continuation right so yeah I
think it all fits together if you think
about it that
way for sure yeah I think defit I think
it works and I can't wait to see this
like I'm psyched there's no there's no
in my mind like oh man they might ruin
it right now I'm just super psyched to
see what happens just who exactly says
sleep is for the week it's 4:30 a.m. boy
that's right commitment I like that what
time zone is that uh um just who exactly
is that like Philippines or
something that's like a big time
difference from us yeah
yeah I like Waldo with a beard picture
that's good see that'd be six time zones
away from where I am so it
probably no more than six
actually yeah probably somewhere in the
Far East so somewhere near Asia actually
just who exactly says he is he is in
AUST
Australian austr Australian bro who's
gonna be an offre you have all the
answers man tell us tell us H have the
emus finally risen up and have like made
like an empire in
Australia yes why why why couldn't they
conquer you man tell us what's happening
what are the origins of code and guos
you have to tell us do go out there and
research it I'm going to fly out to
Australia one of these days and just
like Vlog from there it's like I'm here
on the scene where all the Mysteries
will be solved for Cod Gas season 3 and
people G like this guy is freaking
insane but it'll it'll be fun by the way
uh just who
exactly well how did you like my theory
that uh Lou is hiding in Southern
Australia with the oranges and the Sheep
let me
know I think I I personally think that
Jeremiah has his little orange farm in
Florida
but I don't know that's just some place
I've heard quoted as where he's gone but
it's possible it's not canon at all I
hope that that theory goes viral like
the the orange in Australia that would
be awesome and then all of the YouTubers
comment on
it that would be the best way to get
ahead all the anime YouTubers all of
them even even PewDiePie he watches
anime sometimes
yeah just exactly that says that he has
a farm and Louch is his best friend they
hang out all the time so yeah that's
that's cool and we also have Maya Mimosa
I wonder where she's from if she's also
well with a at the end of her last name
I would say perhaps Russian or Ukrainian
actually although her name is not in
cilic so I'm not definitely Slavic
though shout out to the
Slavs but she says that Coen Cod and
guos were made by martians but we were
we were kind of leaning for Jupiter
rights but you never know man as long as
it's aliens I like the theory as long as
as long as it's ancient Australians I
like the theory obvious obviously it's
the ancients from Stargate that made it
totally they ascended and they made the
collective Consciousness I totally get
that reference totally do you or are you
just humoring me I'm humoring go go
watch Stargate it's a really good Sci-Fi
series anyone else gets that theory if
anyone else gets what I'm referencing
you're
awesome well there yeah so Maya is
polish too so we got a lot of Polish
people we got a lot of Greek people we
got Australians we got all of it man
what a great Community we have here Cod
Gas anime Community I love it I love it
guys welcome again everyone who's in the
chat if you're just joining us we're
talking about the craziest theories in
code gas the most out landish and
therefore clearly best theories
true I wouldn't mind uh n becoming the
antagonist so long we get to see the
Zero armor do we get to see her fall out
of her wheelchair again if she's the
antagonist that's this is what I don't
get guys this is what I don't get and
this feeds into the non only is evil
Theory
because how could Mao get shot like 18
times and be healed and the whole the
only excuse is oh britanian technology
is really good for healing people and
meanwhile Nan's legs can't be repaired
for years and meanwhile she was never
shot in the back like it's not her
spinal cord or something it it's just
she was shot in the legs right so could
it be that just like her blindness she
was faking that too and she's really
like she can walk I feel like she'd
overcome both at the same time though
that's that's my problem with that I
don't feel like there'd be two
Revelations where it's like open my eyes
and then later I can walk you know I
feel like they'd be at the same
time yeah I think both was supposed to
be like a mental trauma thing I think
that's what they're linked to but um if
I mean well with the eye things it it
was supposed to be sensitive to light
same like her legs should um be uh weak
as well because of uh was was it
muscle trophy or whatever you know from
likey
yeah so I I would think it would be
something like that but see as her eyes
were fine to light I'm guessing her
muscles and her legs should have been
good
too yeah like I mean it could be that
like the damage is really extensive
however it was implied in the show that
like their medicine is so like top-notch
and they also have nightmares so you
would imagine they have Prosthetics
right like I feel like prosthetic like
things to help her walk would be easier
to make than a amazingly High functional
nightmare so yeah I don't know I don't
know what they're going to do with that
I think they might make her walk in
somehow like a walking stick with Wills
we have yeah I would not be surprised at
all if we see her walking in R3 because
I imagine the technology is there yeah
for sure Al I I think it perfectly would
Encompass the Branan mindset of seasons
one and two to have unending funds for
the military and none for medical
technology yes by the way Boon is from
Malaysia which is awesome and Brandon
power is Canadian we're also in Canada
bro we're in nager Falls Baby Woo we
have Jason Bell from Texas so yeah we
got a people from all over the world
here just chatting with us having a good
time that's awesome it's it's really
cool thing if we didn't have the channel
and if we didn't have this live stream
we never would have been able to talk to
each other right so that's really cool
we never would have met each other and
as 24 is here what's up um someone H say
not turned into a cyborg I think like if
we saw what happened with um with orange
boy I feel like yeah we could have some
fun stuff with nonell too they can make
her into like a cool half human half
robot thing yeah they have the
technology they should use it I mean
she's the empress she should be able to
get it yeah technology um yeah that's
what it was supposed to be so I'm glad
someone got it yeah I got a $6 Million
Man or whatever uh Frank tyos says that
it's a little serious question how do
you think Lou gain will gain his power
of guos again and that theory is
that again it's it's if he got his code
from
Charles that means that he still his
contract with C2 is still valid because
he didn't have to kill C2 to take her
code he still has a contract with C2
that is valid and he gets code from
someone else so in theory he should be
able to still use his guos power and
have code that is one Theory because C2
is still alive so the contract is still
valid but he also got code from Charles
so that is the theory right now for how
he survived he got code and why he might
be able to also use guos at some point
now it could be that he can't but then
he gets something else happens to allow
him to use G again but I think that that
is the current theory about how he could
have both and then an even more
important Theory uh Troy ol Troy Oliver
says table C got Nina pregnant
theory that is the craziest that is the
craziest Theory well there's obviously
no question we didn't see nah using any
protection so that's that's
true we also have someone from Israel
from New York what's up guys New York
state is actually right beside us we're
in Niagara Ontario she Nina will
probably end up giving birth to a trojan
horse and then inside that Trojan Horse
would be the
baby
yeah Maya says that she would like to
see some Slice of Life between the lch
and C2 in season 3 and I would like to
like I again I hope we get a full season
three like 25 episodes and then they can
start off slow and build up to the
bigger you know villains and conflict
because I really I would also like to
see some buildup first like you know C2
and Louch what what have been they been
doing this whole time and uh what have
what has everyone else been doing and
then maybe we get like a
smaller villain first and then we
realize that behind that villain is a
greater villain like someone who is um
who is an ancient being or someone who
who is connected to the oranges of code
and guos that kind of stuff like I would
love to see that like and
buildup clax for season 3 and uh what
was the other thing oh we have someone
we have from Colombia what's up Adana
where are you from are you from medin
are you from Bogota are you from Cali
are you from
bar are you from Santa Mara are you from
K let us know I personally offend none
of the above by the way I've been to
Colombia so I know the country well
beautiful place beautiful
place um Naruto is asking uh net Naruto
tanu Netflix and chill question mark um
anim man
chill yeah I don't know man I'm
like that's that sounds a little
romantic to me you know too romantic a
little too
romantic well we all know that you know
going to like crunchy roll is more
romantic than
Netflix yeah Netflix Netflix has its
stuff it has its anime including seven
deadly
sins oh Adriana is from Cartana yeah
beautiful city it has like an old really
Old Fort it's it's amazing it's on the
coast so nice and uh Renee says she's
from the Caribbean I love the Caribbean
too I've been to Cuba a bunch of times
Kuba very nice I want to go to Bahama
soon as well
um yeah t very intriguing we'll see if
table
Mak I wonder I feel like they will troll
us and have like a a table reference
like I don't think it'll be direct but
like they'll they'll throw something in
there because they know what a it's
become like everyone's paying attention
so I'm sure they
know I I I also have a crazy Theory
Pizza Hut is going to support rebellions
around the world simply so that they'll
buy more pizzas from them exactly
support everyone right yeah support all
the rebels whatever their ideology we
don't care we're just going to support
you so that we get
more reue no one no one's filming the
like Emperors and stuff no one's filming
the leaders they're all filming the
Rebellion so yeah they're all funding
the
Rebellion
Pizza Hut wants you to join the
Rebellion yeah for crazy theories like
do we think anyone can get brought back
to life like in how we see so many times
in seven deadly sins like will that ever
be a factor in code guos like you I
don't really think resurrection's really
in options here I mean just as a
personal opinion yeah you crazy Theory
discussions crazy theories I I still
don't see anyone getting revived from
the dead anytime soon yeah like I think
that would be kind of like a Copo
because we would feel cheated that's
true you already have an option of
making him Immortal right so why would
you want to do the whole oh just you can
just be resurrected from the dead kind
of thing it seems kind of cheap life
note yeah just who exactly you get my
point plus it will also make Charles's
plan kind of null and void as his plan
was to unite the the dead and the living
and if you could just revive the dead
then there'd be no need for his plan
well I mean a part of it was probably
also to just
to create a place where people can be
one and they can destroy lies and masks
and you know not being your true selves
and War and stuff like that so but
Charles yeah Charles not in equation
anymore which is another thing that's
gonna be interesting in the next season
because we always had Charles in the
background but now all of a sudden
Charles hopefully he's not gonna come
back because I think we had enough of
Charles but there's going to be like
nobody higher than the Lo so it's gonna
be interesting to see what happens I'm
going to miss Charles's ham though
Charles yes you know how he's so
exaggerated in his like his speeches and
stuff I'm gonna I'm gonna miss
him Rene Renee asks what if the mother
so Marian that didn't die but she put
her spit in spit
spit spirit inside nanali so now nanali
go becomes the villain because she's
been possessed by Marian that's that's
crazy and interesting yeah yeah but the
only thing is that I think Maran has to
be in the same room as the person she
possesses well what if someone visited
eye
contact yeah what if someone visited the
for elevator though and she was able to
contact them then like you know you know
like how um Charles went there and he
was able to speak to uh
Clovis what if someone went there and
they were able to see Maran and then she
could project herself into them that
whole thing about speaking to clov is
still one of the weirdest things in the
entire first season in my personal
opinion because it's like it the whole
thing of talking to the dead never comes
up again and it's it just confuses me
like does only Charles get through it or
can anyone in the thought elevator do it
like I I want some
explanations yes that's a good one
because someone mentioned in the chat uh
do you think that there could be a guos
that allows you to speak with the dead
and I think what I got from the the
Charles thing I just spoke with Clovis
was that he was speaking uh using the
sword of Akasha or the thought elevator
to speak with Clovis in the sense of
speaking with the dead so that would be
a way to do it rather than guos I guess
in that world that's just my guess I
don't think there would be a Guess Word
that allows you to speak with the
dead because there's already a mechanism
for it seemingly because again what what
I think that the god in this world of C
yes is is Vector we were talking about
this the other
day it's basically I think that the
ancient civilization the ragar created a
sort of purgatory or whatever you want
to call it a way for all people who die
for their Consciousness to be pulled
together into this that Jupiter looking
thing so that their Consciousness never
passes on
so essentially it's not like dying in
the conventional sense it's not God in
the conventional sense of a creator of
universe it's just this mechanism they
created so that all Consciousness pulled
together into a collective Consciousness
after death yeah so it's kind of like um
basically it could be done with like the
intention of like so that uh you know
people's I guess quote unquote souls are
never lost because I mean before the
world is see you know where would they
have gone I mean that might have been
the intention behind the ancient
civilization actually creating this is
because you know some of their people
died and they had no idea where they
went so it was like okay we have no idea
what lies Beyond so let's make a beyond
that we know is going to happen exactly
they created an afterlife sois that is
what this God thing refers to is they
created an artificial Afterlife by
pooling all Consciousness together
somehow obviously we don't know how that
would work uh it would be ancient
technology that is highly Advanced that
we don't understand yet but yeah I think
I think that like that is my current
theory for what they mean when they say
God which is why when people tell me man
clearly Louch did not kill Charles it
was God who killed him and because God
can do anything I I try to tell them
it's not God in the all powerful sense
of God the Creator it's the mechanism
and the mechanism itself is bound by the
rules of cod and guos because it is
connected to it so if the nun says my
body cannot die without someone taking
code from me then that also applies to
Charles his body cannot vanish unless he
passed his code on to someone else first
because the rules of cod and gas would
apply in the world of sea as well
because the world of sea is connected to
Cod and gas the people that created the
world of sea also created code and
guas am I right people you are always
right always yeah
always there's no arguing there is no
arguing it's a great guys because I'll
kick you off if you if you disagree
there there is no dissent in this
Empire yeah I just I'm just G to start
quoting Charles's speech when he's like
equality is all it doesn't exist the
strong will def destroy the
weak Etc the strong theories destroy the
weak theories blah blah blah blah blah
Charles 26 2017 hashtag hashtag Goen I'm
putting you in charge for making sure to
keep track of chat because I see a lot
of people are putting some good theories
in there and I I don't want us to lose
it so sure bro keep keep a track on
those while I talk I just wanted to say
to everyone who's here again welcome
glad to have you these streams are
awesome we we're only going to do it
once but now we're doing it every single
Saturday because you guys demand it and
it's really cool uh if you want to keep
the discussion going after the stream
you can join the Discord server link is
in the description that's a free app
like Twitter or whatever and then there
you can just register and your chat with
us um uh Vector Maximus and soul MAA
have both been helping a lot on the
server uh kind of keeping order keeping
the piece and we appreciate that and
also I want to point out that Vector
Maximus has his own YouTube channel so
if you want to check him out the great
Ginger Overlord he the link is in the
description and he's actually he does
like he makes Maps like U timeline Maps
uh yeah time
lapses the code gas World you've been
working on that you have some videos of
that already and he's actually going to
be helping us we're going to make a
video eventually about everything we
know about the world of code Gia so
their alternative history how it differs
from our world all that stuff and he's
going to help us make the maps to be
able to demonstrate that custom maps so
yeah definitely support Vector he's a
great guy and has been helping out a lot
just as a general statement for the
history of code guia it's vague as
[__] and that's the video in a nutshell
it's super vague and it pisses me off as
a history person vague as
[__] yeah yeah I love I love it and yeah
for Discord you can do get on your phone
there's an app or you can get it on your
on your desktop and it like I said it's
free and like I'm not saying to join it
because I make any money from it or
anything like we're not sponsored by
we're so rich guys we're so like
absolutely has nothing to do with that
it's just because we love chatting with
people and keeping the conversation
going that's and that that's where you
can chat on us daily when there's no
videos or no streams that's why I keep
shouting out the Discord just for that
reason alone like we don't make any
money from it or anything like that
don't think we're sponsored we're not
trying to occasionally we occasionally
sponsor Pizza Hut that's Pizza Hut is
the only one that ever sponsors
this there also a theory about um people
like combining their
meccas for example suzaku combining his
Mecca with
Collins so we've seen them exchange
Parts between different meccas but would
they do like a Power Rangers thing like
I want to see a Power Rangers thing I
want to see it like Transformers yeah
yeah that could happen who knows and and
like um guran logon so it's been done in
good anime before so that would be cool
to see although it's symbolic though so
I don't know if he wants is aqua and
Colin combining together I don't know no
yeah no it's a sign of them putting
their P behind them and finally making
up yes and making out that's all that
it's a sign of and the fact that they're
joining together in support of evil
Empress n Only no no one will combine
with
Colin yeah nobody but animac can combine
with Colin there's nothing wrong with
hetero combining um vector's words not
mine
guys well I was just getting it out of
the way because we all know it's there
and it's just best to get that kind of
stuff out in the blue yes and then we
have some as long as Goen understands
that it it's not
him this is this is what doesn't even
make sense like he thinks Veta is the
best like most attractive and then yet
he wants the wifeu Colin like yeah most
attractive but she's oie's wifeu man
well see I I think I think Cornelia is
Cornelia is
hot I
agree well said well that's
true have you seen that pick the picture
I put up on Discord that's have to I
occasionally glance at them but I don't
know if I saw that specific one the one
where she's bending over
Louch yes yes yes that oh like one the
one where they're both in school or
something like yeah yeah where where
she's like helping him with his homework
or something yeah yeah up team
approves needs help with homework school
is important soul soul Soul's like have
you seen the picture I posted Soul posts
like 800 pictures a day guys
yeah yeah so there's always it's always
fun stuff to see
no yeah there's there's like yeah
there's a lot of Wu Wars meme Wars a lot
of etchy stuff you know you know how it
works but yeah yeah what else was I
gonna say yeah so definitely to remind
you again we are the next video we're
going to be having for codas is going to
be a interactive video who is your codas
Wu and we're gonna I'm making the quiz
myself and I'm gonna make go and my bro
take it
live while I'm looking at him making
sure that he's not cheating oh I'm
looking at him and you guys can also
take it along with him and then let me
know who everyone let me know who get
who your wife who is and I don't know um
there's seven different options so I
won't tell you yet then we're we're
we're going crazy M me conspiracy theory
every option is actually
Nina it's like the questions are all Bs
it all just leads to
Nina no there are seven real options and
yeah we'll see how it goes and I'm not
going to tell you the options until the
end of the video because I don't want to
ruin it for you to kind of try to look
for a specific option like what you
think would be and yeah I look forward
to goals and uh
losing losing there's no there's no
losing I mean you know fate you can't
you can't do anything fate I'll end up
getting Colin don't
worry and yeah some uh who's who said
Jason Bell says please table [__] be an
option and uh table [__] is a husbando
okay so if someone wants to make a code
GS husbando quiz and include table [__]
I'm totally down for that and we'll find
some girls to take that quiz we'll make
like Brin and Rose from Rand Cafe take
the quiz and see what happens that would
be
hilarious it's like do you like Smooth
objects made I
wood
okay classic Goen just goes too far
what's going on
here classic
Goen um someone said Vector someone said
oh no it was Vector who said Vector of
the
Resurrection well yeah because I
disconnected from the call for a minute
that's why oh did you I didn't see VOR
of the Resurrection yeah I love how
nobody noticed that I was just gone for
like but I'm like you you'll fix it
you'll figure it out no I just I just
yeah I fixed it I'm just used to Vector
always being there because he's always
there in the Discord like he's he's like
an overarching presence so I I did not
realize he wasn't Collective
unconsciousness
SE yeah yeah totally totally I I know
what you're all thinking he's the
collective autocratic consciousness of
the Discord yes
yes I I'll take that title I'll take
that title oh Vladimir SLE is
here I I haven't seen you bro but yeah
he's also in the Discord what's up bro
he says he agrees with soul cornelia's
best Wu I mean I like Cornelia I think
she's good waiu but best I'm not so sure
she's a little harsh she's a little
she's a little hard to uh get close to
in the sense that she would murder you
but I'm sure it'll be worth it in the
end if she doesn't freaking murder you
so but it'll be worth it in the
end some things are worth the risk right
s damn right yeah
Corel a
good
Cornelia Le brania I feel like pretty
well she also doesn't mess
around no pain no gain just who exactly
is
Right Nina X table yes that is the table
[__] guys proper etiquette but that's
the thing that's the thing right okay so
think about it did
Nina want that specific table or would
any table do right is she well obviously
she's a table [__]
so that's the question is it for table
[__] because is a specific table is does
she want him or is she like like you
said like is she like just down for any
table you know that's that's a big U
question that is any time any size she
doesn't care just so long as at the
table
yeah yeah so it's like that's after c2's
name that is one of the big Mysteries I
think that are still unsolved in the
world of kogas Troy says Rock shot and
Lloyd will get married whoever gets them
on their team will crush it them working
together would be amazing for
technological
advancement oh Jose JR says I'm new here
that guy has Annie as his profile
picture I like
him
I'm cool you got soul bro yeah I got I
got soul plenty plenty ma Maya is like
did you just assume the table's gender
yes we did yes yeah I think we need to
clarify with the table what it wants to
identify well actually since uh Nina was
also shown to be like wanting to do
things with Princess yui uh the table
could be either gender
so who knows I don't I I still say table
is
husbando I agree I agree table [__] for
husbando quiz and I I feel like I feel
like out of every like male codia
character after Louch orange is the most
popular I really feel that like orange
has such a fan base it's crazy yeah it
surprised me to be honest I would agree
I would
agree yeah I I think his defend the um
table could is is the male because after
all he does have
wood that's
true yeah let's give that that a clap
guys Cheers Cheers perfect I do try Maya
your questions have been answered golf
collaps everyone golf
collaps
Anu Itachi says orange orange is best
husbando I think uh I think that there's
an argument to be made there for sure
that's
interesting boan would definitely get
suzaku on the test I mean animac would
definitely get suzaku
on I don't know what you're talking
about suzaku is like the worst character
ever I know but I just feel like Against
All Odds you'd get
him and by way the whole Lloyd and rock
shot thing I don't know I kind of
thought that
c some tension there what yeah I I
personally do Cecil Lloyd or just Lloyd
and rock shot and their work because
they're so obsessed with it yeah like
Lloyd doesn't seem to show any interest
in anyone romantically yeah he's kind of
asexual kind of he appears to be like he
would [__] engine yeah he
if it would if it would make it work he
would do it but not for any other reason
oh
man like I don't know if technosexual is
a thing but I feel like that but like I
I still I feel an undercurrent of
tension between him and Cecil man I
don't know oh yeah it's definitely there
I mean Cecil's kind of there as his
Handler and you know like uh basically
making sure he doesn't do anything too
crazy so I mean she's already doing some
of the that a girlfriend wife would prob
be doing for someone like
Lloyd yeah a lot of people a lot of
people think he would make love to
Lancelot Helen Helen says how come
everyone forgets that orange kunun
enjoyed slaughtering civilians in
Shinjuku did he actually enjoy it or was
he just like because he his whole thing
is loyalty right so if he's ordered to
do something he blindly follows it like
he Lo he loves being loyal enjoyed it
yeah because of that reason so I mean he
is definitely a problematic character
because it's right for loyalty he'll do
anything even reprehensible things and
he definitely does start out racist like
most of the characters so there are
there are problems with with him of
course and the reason why everyone
forgets it is because he becomes such a
mimic badass by season by the midseason
two that's why yeah that's where I'm at
now yeah yeah for sure and I mean for
the sake of his badassery and his
loyalty where willing to forgive almost
anything yeah and it's crazy loyalty
like like that Meme it's like what was
200% loyalty 200% loyalty yeah it's like
orange is the color of my
loyalty funny but no yeah I I think it's
like he's like one of those guys that
you definitely want on your side because
of his crazy loyalty and abilities but
like yeah he's one of those guys that he
you don't want to make be your enemy but
you want him on your side he becomes
[__]
RoboCop that's well they're not wrong
they're not
wrong yeah Jer Jeremiah gotwald 50% man
50% machine 100% orange 200
[__]
loyalty that's the one that's the
one uh orange gun please yeah he's such
a good he's such a good mem like table
[__] yes but orange is just his own like
there is such a thing that we don't
speak of on the Discord Ser called the
Great orange War we weren't supposed to
talk well I guess this isn't the Discord
so it's okay I guess this isn't the
Discord yes but the great orange War has
been uh it was a dark
time yeah to say the
least yeah it was one of the great after
the the the Mutiny of the first day of
Discord which was put down by by The
Firm hand of vector
Maximus or bammer
banhammer the great orange War and the
Wu Wars on Discord are some of the
biggest events that we have yeah and
they just always pop up out of nowhere
and also there's a lot of like there's a
lot of REM versus Amelia chats between
me and and soul and a bunch of other
people just randomly happens like we'll
be talking about I don't know death note
and somehow it ends up being about
Amelia and
uh I've given up on stopping the REM
Amilia Wars I've given up because you
just can't stop them from
happening I know because it pisses me
off so much that everyone's so sure and
they're so wrong it just pisses me off
go no do not start that in here both of
you no no no no no not in here not in
here so we're not going to start in here
if you start I'm start ASMR in I'm like
is
it oh yeah no no Remia not on this
stream not on this I won no no not this
time guys I will I will say though I
really hope they do not kill off Orange
in R3 I will say that yeah yeah he will
be missed I'm
concerned I'm concerned because yeah if
you guys see if you guys see uh the PV
orange looks like he's being attacked I
mean he definitely is being attacked but
some people have pointed out this is
another question that I wanted to
address uh some people have pointed out
that they think that that's just a scene
from uh the recap film so a scene from
him getting um shocked by rou in the
Metro station or train station however
you want to call it but I I feel like in
the PB it's clear that he's outside
whereas when he was shot and his
abilities were um shut down byou it was
in the city it was in the Metro station
like that mall right so I feel like
definitely this is a different scene
what what about you guys uh well um me
and Vector were actually looking at it
one time because uh there was someone
else in the chat that actually brought
it up um that it could be like a um
alternate like world like maybe you know
like a um like like some kind of battle
inside his mind or something because if
if you look at the scene where he is
there's nothing but like water
everywhere's blue and then there's a
whole load of like uh
flamingos in the water so it doesn't
look like any like particular place it
just looks like some kind of
abstract I don't know plain kind of made
me think of when uh the SpaceTime
manager person was talking with uh Leila
in
AKO you know that kind of just that just
open expanse on an infinite flat plane
it kind of made me think of that
yeah yeah yeah yeah and flamingos come
from the Caribbean don't they right
so that's the thing but I definitely
think it's a different scene though from
the one in the anime yeah I think that's
a good
point and uh Victor asks I can't it says
I can't wait for the moment when the
Black Knights discover that Louch is
still alive and that's true but then
again Black Knights now hate Lou for
some reason like they think that he's
like the bad guy so I don't know if that
that would actually make them happy or
like I'm sure it would make some people
happy like Colin saw through that like
Colin and people like yeah I feel like
would be like yeah I think that there's
something more going on here but I feel
like Mo most hate him at this point we
don't know if it's going to change in
season three it probably will when they
learn the truth but at this point I
think they all hate and but it'll
definitely still be an epic moment when
like tamaki's like L is alive yeah they
need him for good or ill everyone's
going to lose their [__] when they find
out that the is alive yeah I think it'll
build more distrust as well because I
mean if you think of like the events of
um
R2 and how the Black Knights were
already like distrustful of him and then
after when they did give him a chance he
kind of like got them all like locked up
to then do his plan where he faked his
death as they would see it um yeah I
think they would um they would
definitely still be distrustful of him
but some of them will probably see the
bigger picture that he was trying to
achieve yeah true it depends how much
they need him right guys because if if
they need him then there's not really a
choice that's usually how Louch zero
operates he shows up when people need
him so there's no choice like do we
really want to trust him we have to
trust him kind of thing you have no
option but to fail exactly remember when
he when he invited him on top of the
mountain and then he's like all right
guys so yeah we're actually taking down
uh this cornelia's team and if you don't
do it then we're all dead so you got to
do it yeah yeah yeah you can either live
with me or you can die without me
basically amazing yeah might be like the
lesser of two evils in it Jon Bell says
Jason Bell says Tamaki is the reason
everything that went wrong no I like
Tamaki he's crazy I like him yeah was
fun guy yeah he's funny I like him oh
Tamaki might be dead in season three
because his original voice actor di
didn't it they might him out I don't
think they'll kill him just because of
that I mean they might kill him off but
I don't think it would be just because
of that yeah no they could do though it
could be like you know one of the um
terrorist bombs or whatever you know
because he's supposed to be like a
politician or something now so yeah he
that was always his dream too wasn't it
he could get hit his dream are we
talking about oi
no Tamaki the guy with the headband yeah
the crazy one yeah yeah the stupid one
Phantom black is here what's up
bro he's asking do we think that orange
C2 and Louch knew that Louch would
become
immortal I I want to say that orange and
C2 definitely knew which would then mean
that Louch would have to have known
because and I know some of you think
that louo wouldn't have known that he
would get code but I disagree again
because um I think that Orange's
Behavior clearly shows that he knew that
Louch would survive because like it's
one thing for orange to out of loyalty
say okay I will lead contribute to you
getting killed because you told me but
it's another thing for him to be excited
about it and even happy so that tells me
that orange knew he was BEC moral and
also C2 when C2 is feeling sad about
what's happening and shown in the church
and stuff my interpretation is that she
is actually sad because she knows that
now Louch has code and that's to her
that's been a curse and a you know
burden so she now is praying for him to
be able to take that burden I don't I
never thought that she thought that he
was actually gonna die uh in those final
scenes that's a cool idea that's a cool
interpretation because that is one of
the yeah soul oh okay uh no I was going
to say so how do you uh interpret the
scene with C2 uh in a church like
praying as Lucha is going to be stabbed
is she like upset that he's like giving
up his life as he knows it or yeah yeah
then he now will be cursed with cold
like she has been but is it really a
curse anymore if they've got each other
exactly yeah that's yeah that's a good
point because I mean the curse of the
king is to be lonely I mean that's
stated outright but if I mean they're
king and queen I guess you could say so
they're together at the least yeah but
like at this point she's like she's not
sure if Alou will regret his decision
right it's a big thing like there's no
going
back yeah yeah it's up for
interpretation definitely both sides
have valid
points but the point is he's alive damn
it he's
alive okay
yeah yeah that's going to be I mean it's
going to be cool and I'll definitely
enjoy seeing more Slice of Life moments
more Cod G
moments D tenzen are you the guy that's
been challenging me in the comments
about the zero rean film the special
film because I think that I think he's
the guy so I want to address this point
right now live if that's
him oh we have El lot here what's up bro
you know how we always say that hold on
hold on now hold on because I wanna
address D tenzen all right so he asked
me he asked me uh because in the special
we were talking about that poster that
was created as a way to promote that
special film uh zero requim film that
came out uh uh back in 2009 or 2008 and
obviously our argument in the video was
that that poster shows a scene from
season 3 that it's clear that it hint
that there should have been a season 3
or that there will be uh now we know
that in the film itself so the special
edition film uh it's shown that C2 at
the end is talking saying things like oh
Louch died I'm paraphrasing but it's not
a tragedy he died with a smile on his
face because of the zero requium he got
what he wanted in the end that kind of
thing and again the way I interpret this
is first of all I've heard the rumor
several times and I think it's true that
codas was supposed to have more episodes
75 episodes and then they cut it at 50
because Sunrise didn't have faith in the
show so to me it's like they always
intended for the L to survive and get
code and for the story to continue
however when they couldn't anymore
because of budget they decided to just
end it at the zero requium and leave it
open-ended for us and then we talked
about this previously some people have
stated that L um the creators of code
Gia said that Louch was actually a dead
well not really dead but they said Lou's
story is over something along those
lines implying that he might be dead but
my interpretation of that has always
been that when they're saying the Louch
is dead or that his story is over they
were talking about the Louch we know
because we know that when someone gets
code uh they become a different person
goes and stop rubbing your mic um I'm
not rubbing it so but you keep rubbing
it it keeps going to to you um so
basically Louch would not be Louch
anymore so just like C2 her real name is
not C2 she becomes C2 because she gets
Cod so she becomes a different being an
immortal being a different person in
many ways um I think that was what they
would be saying about Louch as well so
the Louch we know the Mortal Louch is
dead and he does technically die uh in
the sense that in my theory that I
believe in he has to come back to life
in order to uh gain his code for his
code to activate so the Louch we know
does die and that would explain you know
c2's speech and it would explain what
the creators might have said but in the
end Lou does still live but as a
different being now as someone with code
and yeah so that would be my
interpretation of that whole C2 thing
and the reason C2 again we just
mentioned this earlier the reason C2
would be upset is that even if she knew
that he would be immortal is because
she's always thought of the code as a
curse she's known it's hard to live for
all those centuries uh so many things
lose meaning do you really have any real
friends anymore do you have does
anything you know does time passing mean
anything to you anymore so it is in a
way a curse immortality it's it's a
wellestablished topic in fiction and so
even though she is happy she would be
happy that he doesn't die she's also
wondering like did Louch make the right
decision by taking Charles's code will
he regret it will he suffer like she has
suffered so I think that's what explains
c2's sadness in this uh or or
like uncertainty in this
moment I'd say that's fair yeah yeah
yeah makes
sense yeah I'm glad I'm glad he came in
uh be into the the stream because like I
didn't want to have to type all that out
in the comment die T
in well yeah that would have taken a
while there's nothing more annoying than
having to type out a very long YouTube
comment yeah but when you do it once you
can just copy and paste it so that's
this is true this is
true you know what it's kind of funny
you know because of the uh special
edition um zero Ry a minut it that's the
one where it basically has the dialogue
at the end where uh C2 says that Louch
is dead but you know that poster that
shows Louch with the dog yeah that is
actually from the special edition zero
yes exactly so to me that even that
itself says that even in that film that
poster is telling you something it's
telling you that yeah do don't take this
ending as the final ending kind of thing
like otherwise why would that poster be
promote that specific poster be
promoting that specific film there is
like to me it's like a clear hint like
it's not a coincidence it's like they
could have used any image right so why
this specific one so yeah that to me
feel backs that whole theory that it's
like yeah we're telling you that he's
dead but you know there's more to it
than that the person who is dead is not
who Louch is anymore but that doesn't
mean that you know that his story isn't
different now that that the story won't
continue and even like what
is the freaking theme of the ending of
the ending song what is it called it's
like continued story or something yeah
continued
story team of the final
scene of codas where where the car
driver is is called continued story like
no kidding it's called continue story so
it's like it all points to that they
wanted us to know that the the sequel
was always planned they always wanted to
continue the story
guys damn
[Music]
it that's it that's the one
one that's the
one and don't ask why I have it
memorized we all do we all do it's we we
know you sing it in a shower it's okay
it's
fine you don't want to hear what I sing
in you're watching that Golden
Hand yeah and D tenen says can the
continued story refer to his friends and
family and yeah it could so again if
that was all we had if that was the only
evidence we had without that poster
without all the other stuff with Char's
code without not only seeing his
memories I would say yeah like that's
not enough for me to go on but I'm just
saying all together put together I feel
like it creates a really solid argument
for
everything and I have to take a bathroom
break guys so please uh cool say some
stuff please don't make us be
entertaining on our own I'm not good
that entertaining here Buzzard is here
is here ghostav is here helian b3ta Etc
so or beta so
yeah to go and your mic is like my ears
your mic is like terrible like take it
off it's it's it sounds like it's
farting or something is
it still not sure how to describe it
it's
better okay it's recovered yeah okay so
I was gonna say uh I think that the Way
co Louch you know how non has always
been his major motivation yeahh after
is kind of comes
back hey what's up guys it's Goen guys
hey what's
up a wild anime appears it's like
Inception right now but I was saying
yeah it's always been like when she
comes back tries to do yui's role and
kind of bring back the administrat zone
of Japan he he is wondering should I
give up if Nal is protected by suzaku do
I need to be in the Black Knights
anymore he has this crisis identity
crisis and he decides to do it anyway
because it's beyond nonell so I feel
like Nal will still not prevent him from
doing stuff even if she is
empress yeah oh yeah kind of he kind of
moved uh beyond that kind of emotional
crutch I would say yeah exactly so we
shouldn't put too much weight on that
but definitely it's got to be a factor
by the way I got any uh embarrassing
stories of animac to talk about while
he's away no no cuz it's being recorded
guys it but don't you
again okay the stream just rename it
embarrassing Animax
stories he comes back he's like what's
up
guys welcome to embarrassing anx stories
2017 no animac is cool and I'm I'm
really glad that we have anime to share
I'm glad like we both have anime because
it would have been like stupid if it was
just me but now it's cool that we have
we're brothers we can talk about anime
we can share anime I mean it's a pretty
awesome
setup yeah yeah I'm sure not a lot of
people have that as well no for sure
most people are loners in it yeah I mean
I'd be I'd be doing it anyways but it's
cool that it's cool that we have like
double the Manpower
and we can motivate each
other yay for op
topic he's back all right everybody shut
up we we can't let him know we can't let
him
know oh well little do you know that in
the bathroom I had my cell phone so I
was listening the whole time uh oh
that's weird man that is that is
creepy I watch your faces when I'm in
the bathroom that deal with I I didn't
need to hear that I didn't need to hear
that well it thankfully he never saw my
face you're right time to deactivate the
camera and now it's back clad after
Story made on bukry well you you're not
the only one bro I cried some manly
tears some manly Comm
tears did your tears pierce the
heavens yes they did and some people
were talking about uh
um Phantom black says hey animac in the
continued story song There Are lyrics
about raindrops maybe hints at c2's name
damn that's a good point Phantom
black we got look at those lyrics does
anyone have the lyrics give it set it up
in the Discord paste does the lyrics in
the Discord because that is a good point
Phantom black does it again guys he
always has some cool insights man good
work bro let's let's see if we can get
that going on in Discord because I
really want to figure out c2's name if
we can figure out c2's name because
that's a clear thing like so if they say
it to give it to us in season three and
we figur out befor like that's something
we clearly know if we were right or
wrong so that would be
amazing God bless our King it's a bright
light day let us Worship in your Triumph
and this story is mine and this moment
is mine can I steal your pain and shed
it away to amend this pain to avoid this
pain can I share this pain and carry
away and this story is mine and this
moment is mine can I steal your pain and
shed it yeah to the day in my new era to
the day in my dreaming land towards the
light yeah that's that's like what the
the lyrics are I'm going to copy and
past them and throw them in yeah thought
you were just saying stuff bro no no
those those are those are the lyrics no
I was reading them did you get did you
get that from anime lyrics.com
lyrics anime.
WordPress Ean 89 is like I know cce's
name it's best
girl
no but yeah U put in the Discord and
we'll analyze it because yes like Maya I
think pointed out in the chat that c2's
whenever c2's name is mentioned there's
like a drop of water or a raindrop so
that I definitely think that's a hint
like I definitely think that's a hint I
I looked up
like names for water different languages
like Latin and stuff to see if I could
find any like anything that's the root
of a modern name but I
couldn't but yeah I do a lot of research
but uh yeah let's do that thing in
Discord let's see if we can come up with
some ideas for c2's
name L snow a lot
too obviously her name is cheese
cheese for cheesec
gun and it fits with CC you are what
youz John yeah I mean you're not
wrong Aquaman that's that's her
name Aquaman
watch her name be H2O says Maxwell
Lacy we knew it we knew it H2O Pizza
girl uh C2 is is britanian not Japanese
C2 Maya is shown to be from Europe she's
but not specifically where in Europe
yeah like we're guessing like
France maybe even uh Branan like English
France when England held land in France
yeah because uh VOR pointed out that in
the Manga she has said in Reena I
believe of the darkness um I believe it
was Nell nightmare of Nell it was say
that she fought in the Hundred Years War
okay now we don't think that not only
not is Canan but like it's a hint right
so if she fought in the War like she's
definitely I would say definitely from
Europe and like when when you see the
scenes of her flashbacks when she's a
child the scenery is very European right
like Med medieval European so we know
she's European perhaps France perhaps
English and um by the architecture maybe
Irish but yeah so that's what we would
be looking for the name was it in Akita
when she had the uh I think it's was it
the was it Portuguese Jesuit robes uh
that was renia that was
Ren Ren where she had the Jesuit robes
yeah yeah yeah yeah well those were
dubbed as Portuguese so I don't the yeah
that Jesuits are Portuguese those were
Portuguese mission
Aries
yeah yeah like so that that would be a
cool thing to dis discuss in the Discord
right after this to try to see if we can
come up with some solid theories for her
name but like with actual
evidence yeah we'll never be able to
prove it like once and for all but yeah
it be fun to
speculate yeah it would be cool to to
find it some theories but with actual
like evidence like this is what we I
think because of this this and this
reason not just like well I think her
name should be uh
Lucy because I like that
name yeah proof proof is good well
didn't she get turn into a USB drive
yeah sa sabage says she look in Japanese
do
though yeah she's def
Japanese in
codeos septile tube's like I'll asked
him like he's like maybe her name is
Estephanie I'm like what's your basis
he's like I was just bored so I put a
random
name well I mean as good reason as
any I
suppose anything is
[Music]
possible yeah yeah like let's take this
discussion to the disc after this
because I would
like who's like away dishes over
there yeah I I it's not me this
time it's definitely not
me
back what that's why he's staying so
quiet like what guys I'm not washing
dishes right now yeah no totally both my
hands are free as you can see
good keep them in view
please we can't trust you
Hector so do you guys think schneizel is
a hero or
villain that's one question from Jason
Bell uh I'd label him as an anti villain
personally
like well it's like a villain who does
all the wrong things for the right
reasons his case he wanted piece but he
nuked people to do it so you mean like
an anti-hero then yeah an anti-hero
is I guess more I there is a difference
I'd have to look up the definition again
like Louch for me would be like an
anti-hero because he's kind of like the
her we're following but I get the idea
of anti villain I think that's a cool
way to look at it because everyone in
coas has to an extent some redeeming
qualities which is what I like about the
show it's not it's not like Superman
versus Lex
here's the one they may be more noble or
heroic than the anti-hero but they use
means just as but they are the
antagonist and they use means that are
just as um just as vable yeah and
questionable yes yeah definitely an
antagonist for the show for sure yeah I
personally just don't like schneizel I
think he's a douche yeah well he is the
older brother so they
now now I need to know which one of you
is older simply so I know who that was
aiming at I'm it should be clear he's
years I guess six years as an older
brother I take offense yeah I know like
he's a he's a
discriminator they they just don't they
just don't understand the hierarchy do
they they will learn that place though
they will learn they will learn they
will
learn your title on on Discord is the
Royal BL brother but mine is
imperator I let you have fun on that
Discord yeah yeah the Discord is where
all the power is my
friend yeah the YouTube channel is
nothing power purpose of the great
Discord the great Discord Wars that's
funny I am a younger brother says
assassin gaming which is cool oh younger
brothers assassin gaming
nice yeah yeah younger brothers like
younger brothers have it easy like they
parents always spoil them because
they're like the
rant yeah like just just you younger
brothers you got everything like you
have your older brother to help you to
guide you through life plus your parents
spoil you plus for some reason you end
up being taller
cover you and get in trouble for you
that's that's what really annoys me the
taller part hey man I I I I helped you
just as much as you help me
bro including including showing you
showing you wait for it code
guos
[Music]
oh the origin story has been revealed
Renee says younger brothers are evil so
yeah see
n younger evil
Empress coincidence completely different
ball game bro no brother same same thing
same thing Louch is the younger brother
of
schneizel yeah brother
though half brother brother brotheris is
the younger brother of
odius yeah Odus sucks
too so I don't know if he sucks he just
is just he doesn't do anything I mean
yeah yeah I'm okay with that sure yeah
don't blame her it's okay yeah that
that'll be another crazy Theory
meanwhile like what is odys has been
doing in Australia the whole time when
we don't see him guys he's he's the one
like doing all the crazy [__] like just
in season three it all comes out it's
like Odysseus was one step ahead the
whole time he was engaged in an
odyssey schne always just the
puppet do do you guys think another
could have come into the freight or do
you believe that they're all dead with a
pen Dragon yeah I think they could
definitely have more siblings because
like Charles was a prolific uh father
man yeah he had 108 wives for goodness
sakes so actually yeah I believe that's
the only know we know of six wise but
yeah thought it was me had 108 actual
consorts yeah I think that clearly
Charles is best
husbando for many women yeah I think for
in terms of quantity
alone many chose him but yeah yeah I
think definitely a sibling that is a
interesting point like another sibling
that we didn't know about that might
have been hiding in Australia right
right with the aliens he just comes out
of Australians I will now take the
throne and the other thing someone
mentioned in the chat like way back
earlier uh that they're wondering what
Louch was doing for that whole
month uh
between him taking power or like the
last we hear of him after he takes over
the Black Knights and stuff and defeats
schneizel and the big coronation zero
requium thing so that's an interesting
question to like whether season 3 will
explore some of the plans he set into
motion back then well obviously he was
getting
drunk his sorrow obvious you're like
obvious
obviously he was off getting
drunk Maxwell Lacy says Charles is the
ultimate player and yes he is I don't
think anyone can argue with that like I
think is his son only genas Khan could
could have like had him
beat I still don't think gas Kong had
him
beat like I think genas Kong had like
500 something direct children with like
who knows how many
wives
so how many wives do you
guys I think one is
enough could you imagine that headache
well always a nice guy always a
gentleman no it's true it's true like
people are like oh having many wives
that sounds like a good idea but uh yeah
it's that's a lot that's a lot of uh
responsibility obligation
uh good luck going shopping that's all I
can say good luck going shopping what
the [__] well there's a reason that
Charles had to be emperor of a third of
the world to have that
many
Jesus SS like
offended aan a89 ask if Lou were to
create a new world order would you join
it and I feel like I would support him
but I would advise him not to try to
create like a world police with the
Black Knights like he seemed to try to
do like a world Army Global Army because
I just don't think it's going to work
like nationalism is too strong a force
and people are going to Rebel they're
like I don't want to be ruled by someone
from like half a world away just like
the Japan Japanese didn't want to be
learn ruled by britannians so in that
sense I think that I would I would like
a world where Louch can do his plotting
but I think that he he still has some
things to learn about diplomacy and the
way International Affairs should be
handled and I will teach him I will be
his
adviser you use that poly yeah political
science baby zero is against usually
National stuff though like because he's
all about he's all about anyone can be
in the Black Knights and that Japan is
not something that you are like let's
say ethnically but it's something in the
heart well he but that's still
nationalism if you say you can say that
you know make what makes you Japanese is
not just
ethnicity but the
factal nationalism in fact that you're
emphasizing Japanese as independent as
worthy of independent recognition and
self-rule is still a form of nationalism
now and I think that the Black Knights
definitely are nationalist Japanese and
again nationalist is is not actually a
bad word there's different forms of
nationalist just that now it's been like
purposely in the media portrayed as a
bad word because they want to push Glo
globalization right and CA mopolitan ISM
because that works for big businesses
that control media Illuminati confirmed
but uh but yeah I think that Black
Knights are definitely nationalist but
and then I feel like Louch has to kind
of get his stuff in order can be like on
the one hand yes you know we want
Japanese Independence on the other on
the other hand we want every everyone to
be ruled by the Black Knights or yeah
well that's the whole idea beneath you
know the ufn which
is well yeah it's basically uh you a
very powerful United Nations I mean
everyone has to give up their standing
militaries and all that
stuff also was was there any any was
there ever confirmation that the uh that
the britanian empire under Nell either a
released the areas or B joined the
ufn yeah I don't know I I assumed that
they would just have joined the
ufn but because n onlyi was on board for
that kind of thing but again we don't
know for sure I don't think we do at
least yeah but if they do join then the
other nations would probably force uh
Force what they wanted Louch to do when
he basically you know pseudo petition to
join which was you know basically limit
the amount of power britan's got because
otherwise they dominate by population
count
yeah just who exactly says that
breakfast is approaching where he is in
Australia so I hope you're GNA have some
oranges for breakfast my friend and say
hello to uh situ Louch
uh Jeremiah and Ana who I am sure are
hiding in the Murray river region of
Southern
Australia see bro thanks for
coming um have a good day by the way by
the
way sabage come
on funny but um yeah so I was thinking
like we could wrap it up slowly the
stream and continue the discussion then
on the Discord server if you want to
join the Discord again link is in the
description it's completely free app you
just join so we can chat when there's no
videos when there's no streams we can
keep the chats going feel free to join
and because me and Goan want to get to
work on the next cods video so we want
to make sure that we uh have enough time
for that but uh unless you guys want to
say anything else we can slowly wrap it
up no I think we've covered just about
everything all the crazy theories oh
creep says creep says vector is orange
confirmed
well I
mean 100%
wrong you have a strong case for Orange
right
now by the way some people are asking
for the Discord Link in the chat if you
want to give it to I'll throw it there
yeah Vector will give you guys the
Discord Link in the chat and it's also
in the description by the way um and
yeah so best the theory left for last uh
creep Ellen good work uh Vector is
orange
confirmed orange is the color of his of
his loyalty and his
hair glorious magnificent
copper his loyalty is
200% 200% all the loyalty is
mine yeah stream will be ending now so
we can go get to work on the next video
look out for that guys we're going to
have that today or tomorrow depending on
how much the editing takes but yeah look
out for that you're going to be able to
interact with us find out who your true
code wifeu is and yeah the conversation
will continue on the Discord I want to
thank Goen my bro for being here go
welome
bro talking about anime as always I'm
gonna go up there and then teach you
some some hierarchy of the older brother
when this is done um it do it vector
vector thank you for joining us as well
Vector has done a lot to support the
channel and the Discord and his link for
his YouTube channel is in the
description if you want to check him out
and show him some love
Vector thanks for having me it's great
fun as usual and everybody go to the
Discord uh no Wu wars in the main chat
please or else I think I'll lose my mind
at some
point but otherwise you know go crazy
have fun be a jerk and I hopefully won't
have to kick anyone yeah and soul Maka
thank you as well for uh joining us bro
yeah man always glad to be here and
everything yeah uh um another thing I'd
like to say as well um every night
usually we have a a voice chat session
where just loads of people on the
Discord we just jump in and join in we
also um then get a link for uh rabbit
where we would uh all together watch a
like some anime or whatever we'll stream
it so yeah it's fun it's good fun yeah
yeah so that we Discord also has voice
chats where you can just like you see
it's just audio you don't see the faces
but you just chat audio with other
people in the Discord that's fun as well
I try to join it whenever I can as well
so yeah definitely thanks everybody um
for being the on the stream thanks
everyone who came to the chat and
watched we appreciate you guys uh you're
the reason we're doing this every week
now because there was just so much
demand for it and we love doing this we
enjoy it and we will keep going new
video coming soon look out for that and
until next time see you space Cowboys
Bang